politics is show business but for ugly
people Everyone Knows stand-ups from
watching Jimmy Kimmel or whatever and
they see a couple of minutes was I had a
late night gear model late night it's a
bit of a blur but I think I'm dating
Pete Davidson now
but so many people who came out on my
last tour they haven't sat through a
25-minute Ivan Deckers comedy set which
is mind-blowing I found something harder
than a long distance relationship close
distance relationship anybody tried that
I loved somebody like David Letterman
growing up would Rick ever do a nightly
show like that I don't know but on this
show I interview the comics yes and
that's that's new for me I mean I've
done this and talked to people like
yourself my entire life that's actually
a compliment but anyway go on
so who knows it's a whole new set of
skills for me we all saw the slap that
was heard around the world at the Oscars
do you feel like comedians at this point
in 2022 have to walk a bit on eggshells
I don't think so I think there's a lot
of conversations about you know what's
acceptable and how dangerous you can be
and what you can and cannot talk about
but there's the comedian only has one
job and that's to be funny yeah and if
they're funny they can say whatever they
want